per aufzug in den weltraum das ist keine
unrealistische utopie sondern absolut
realisierbar schon heute es gibt nur
einen haken klicks um science and future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's per aufzug in den
weltraum das ist der titel eines neuen
buches im rowohlt verlag und mit diesem
buch kann man in die zukunft sehen ich
beschreiben in dem buch realistische
szenarien wie den ersten kontakt mit
außerirdischen die krönung der schöpfung
in form der künstlichen intelligenz oder
eben den aufzug in den weltraum das
alles wird so oder so ähnlich früher
oder später passieren
und warum das begründe ich
wissenschaftlich der link zum buch ist
hier unter mir aber am ende habe ich
dazu noch mal eine ganz besondere bitte
in diesem video geht es um den baldigen
bau eines aufzugs in den weltraum in den
weltraum zu gelangen
ja das war schon immer ein
menschheitstraum und der visionär jules
verne beschrieb bereits 865 in seinem
roman von der erde zum mond einen
raumflug zu unserem trabanten fast exakt
100 jahre später hat die menschheit
dieses lange für utopisch gehaltene ziel
erreicht dass unsere zivilisation diesen
traum in die realität umgesetzt hat
führt uns vor augen es ist möglich
vermeintlich unerreichbare ziele zu
erreichen
vor allem schien es lange unmöglich der
ert gravitation zu entkommen woher die
energie dazu nehmen es war wie ein
fliehendes ziel je weiter die entfernung
von der erde sein sollte desto mehr
treibstoff wurde benötigt und die mit
treibstoff benötigt wurde desto schwerer
wurde die rakete bis die technik im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert so weit
entwickelt war dass das mehr an
treibstoff dennoch mehr als nur sein
eigengewicht aus dem erdorbit befördern
konnte mit der bis heute immer noch
größten gebauten rakete der saturn 5
gelang dass für unmöglich gehaltene 1969
landeten mit neil armstrong und buzz
aldrin zwei amerikanische astronauten
auf dem mond
doch für das gesamte apollo-programm
dass dahinter stand wurde ein
gigantischer aufwand getrieben
insgesamt bis zu 400.000 menschen
arbeiteten daran
es kostete nach heutigem wert des dollar
120 milliarden und wurde deshalb
schließt
sich eingestellt und auch das
nachfolgeprogramm der bau und einsatz
der spaceshuttles wurde am ende wegen
des hohen aufwands aufgegeben seitdem
wird fieberhaft nach einem weg gesucht
die raumfahrt wieder realisierbar zu
machen
wir schießen zwar laufen satelliten in
den orbit und senden sondern in die
welten des alls doch astronauten noch
einmal zum mond zu schicken oder sogar
zum mars das haben wir bisher nicht
geschafft es ist immer noch zu teuer und
zu aufwändig innen maske ist jedoch mit
seinem privaten project space ex auf
einem guten weg oder auch jeff beste
amazon-chef er möchte mit seinem
unternehmen blue origin auch schon bald
wieder menschen auf den mond schicken
und bei dieser mission soll dann laut
nasa auch zum ersten mal eine
astronautin den mond betreten richard
bransons unternehmen virgin galactic
arbeitet daran raketen mit flugzeugen in
die oberen luftschichten zu bringen und
von dort aus zu starten was durch die
dünne luft und die geringere
erdanziehungskraft erheblich treibstoff
sparen würde die verwirklichung des
ziels die kosten zu senken und ergebnis
zu bauen
die wieder passagiere zum mond bringen
können das rückt also in erreichbarer
nähe und es geht dabei um nicht mehr und
nicht weniger als die eroberung des
weltalls es werden transportmittel
benötigt die astronauten astronauten und
fracht kostengünstig und im großen stil
in den weltraum bringen können erst wenn
diese frage gelöst ist werden wir den
weltraum weiter erkunden können erst
dann wird es möglich größere raumschiffe
zu konstruieren und aus der taufe zu
starten raumstation zu bauen und andere
planeten zu besiedeln erst dann können
wir die idee umsetzen und so über den
weltraum zu verteilen dass unsere
spezies nicht mehr durch eine
katastrophe auf der erde vernichtet
werden kann oder sich durch den
klimawandel selbst auslöschen stephen
hawking war es die letzte große
herausforderung der menschheit um das
überleben unserer zivilisation zu
sichern
eines der spektakulärsten projekte wie
die reise zum mond lange zeit als
unmögliches unterfangen angesehen ist
der aufzug ins weltall auch diese idee
stammt aus dem 19 jahrhundert und genau
aus dem jahr 1895 der russe konstantin
ziolkowski stellt sie sich inspiriert
von dem wenige jahre zuvor
fertiggestellten eiffelturm einen 35
1786 kilometer hohen turm vor mit einem
lift in den
allerdings ist die idee in der form nie
verfolgt worden ein derart hohes bauwerk
ist mit den heutigen technischen mitteln
einfach nicht denkbar
eher schon ist eine andere
herangehensweise an das projekt
interessant ein langes seil das bis in
den weltraum gespannt wird enden soll es
im geostationären orbit der erde wo
objekte in einer entfernung um die erde
kreisen der sich gravitation und
fliehkraft bei der gleichen winkel
geschwindigkeit wie die der erde
ausgleichen
das objekt befindet sich dadurch immer
über dem selben punkt lange wurde es als
senkrecht verlaufenes seil in den
weltraum gedacht doch durch die
erddrehung gibt es einen mitnahmeeffekt
der ähnlich wie beim abschleppen eines
autos wirkt die erde zieht an dem seil
und deshalb muss es deutlich länger sein
als 35.000 7 186 kilometer nämlich rund
100000 kilometer eine bedingung die es
nicht gerade leicht macht ein solches
seid so konstruieren es würde nämlich
unter seinem eigenen gewicht zerreißen
mit stahl würde das schon bei einer
länge von etwa 30 kilometern passieren
doch einer der experten für dieses thema
der physiker bradley adwords ist sich
sicher dass alle technischen
herausforderungen zu bewältigen sind
seit 1998 veröffentlichte studien zum
weltraum aufzug 2000 2003 wurden sie
sogar von der nasa unterstützt nach
seinem konstruktionsplan würde das seil
nicht unter dem eigengewicht reißen der
aufzug würde sich natürlich langsamer
viel langsamer als raketen bewegen dafür
aber mit weitaus weniger energie viel
größeren frachten transportieren können
statt nämlich unmengen an energie
aufzubringen um die erdbeschleunigung
von 98 1 meter pro sekunde im quadrat zu
überwinden muss hier nur die energie
aufgewendet werden um die höhendifferenz
zu überwinden
das seil trägt das gewicht und hält den
aufzug auf dem erreichten level
es ist ein einfaches aber geniale
prinzip wie aber wird die kabine mit
energie versorgt wie muss das seil
beschaffen sein damit es nicht heißt wie
also kann ein seil hergestellt werden
das extrem leicht und langes wyplay etwa
2 diese probleme gelöst zu haben
und das im wahrsten sinne des wortes
zentrale element des aufzugs soll ein
seil aus kohlenstoff-nanoröhrchen sein
mit einem durchmesser von 3 mm ist
dieser faden in der lage ein gewicht von
45 tonnen zu tragen ein kilometer dieses
salz wiegt nur 400 gramm das seil wird
dabei an einem satelliten in 35 1786
kilometern höhe und an einer plattform
zum beispiel auf see befestigt dadurch
könnte es auch problemlos
weltraumschrott ausweichen indessen gibt
es zweifel an der realisierbarkeit das
material für das seil existiert zwar
aber kann daraus wirklich ein so langes
seil hergestellt werden bisher gibt es
keine forschungen dazu wie nanoröhrchen
für ein solches sei zu optimieren werden
aber für die lösung anderer probleme
gibt es schon ideen so könnte die kabine
von der erde aus durch laserstrahlen mit
energie versorgt werden schwingungen die
durch luftbewegungen und die kabine
selbst verursacht werden könnten durch
gegen schwingungen von der bodenstation
ausgeglichen werden beschädigungen
könnten durch ständige reparaturen
behoben werden edwards ist sich seiner
sache sicher und auch das amerikanische
unternehmen lift bot arbeitet am space
elevator sag mal zurzeit per
crowdfunding geld ein um den weltraum
aufzug tatsächlich zu bauen die kosten
werden auf 15 milliarden dollar
geschätzt
in japan ist man schon weiter 2018 wurde
das modell eines aufzuges an der
internationalen raumstation iss getestet
zwei cube satz also mini satelliten
wurden mit einem seil aus der stoff
verbindung kessler verbunden und ein
container daran mit einem motor hin und
herbewegt der test wurde von einem
forschungsteam der universität von ski
zucker und dem bauunternehmen obayashi
durchgeführt bis mitte des jahrhunderts
soll der aufzug realität geworden sein
so genannte klein bar sollen dann
zwischen einer raumstation und der erde
hin und her fahren die kleinbahn sollen
18 meter lang sein
ein durchmesser von sieben metern haben
und rund 30 passagiere in den weltraum
befördern können
der nächste schritt auf dem weg ins
weltall könnte also zunächst ihnen einen
aufzug führen ein ziemlich utopischer
plan aber denkbar so wie jules verne die
reise zum mond vorhergesehen hat und es
wäre ein viel größerer schritt für die
menschheit als ihn damals den armstrong
getan hat vielleicht ist er nicht ganz
so symbolträchtig aber er wird unsere
welt verändern
von einem auf den anderen tag könnten
wir menschen und fracht für fast zu
vernachlässigen die kosten in den
weltraum bringen und
um flugkörper in verschiedenen höhen vom
aufzug entkoppeln und auf die reise
schicken das eröffnet im wahrsten sinne
des wortes ganz neue dimensionen
missionen in die entlegensten bereiche
unseres sonnensystems wären realisierbar
und eine stippvisite ins all
könnte sich fast jeder leisten in eine
wirklich unglaubliche entfernung von der
erde
denn die internationale raumstation iss
kreist in den täglich 400 kilometern um
unseren heimatplaneten die raumstation
am ende des aufzuges wäre 90 mal weiter
von der erde entfernt als die ss und
übrigens die zahlreichen studien und
überlegungen zeigen dass all diese
techniken jetzt schon zum bau von
weltraum aufzügen genutzt werden könnten
nämlich auf dem mars und auf dem mond
und da würde schon heute verfügbares
material wie kessler vollkommen
ausreichend die menschheit könnte also
vielleicht schon viel früher einen
solchen weltraum aufzug einsetzen als
wir heute an
durch die forschung in diesem bereich
sind wir diesem ziel fast unbemerkt so
nahe gekommen dass wir es zunächst an
anderen orten umsetzen könnten um mit
den dort gemachten erfahrungen rückt an
solche aufzug dann auch auf der erde in
greifbare nähe
das ist übrigens eines von vielen
spannenden themen aus meinem neuen buch
bei aufzügen den weltraum der link ist
hier unter oder auch hier aber er könnte
auch etwas gutes tun ich würde mich
tierisch freuen wenn es das buch in
vielen buchhandlungen gebe also kaufte
es bitte dort und unterstützt in diesen
schweren zeiten die buchhandlungen bis
dann bleibt dran